foreign
starts this hour in Oklahoma City hey
Mary welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jane oh my gosh I'm so
excited to be here I really didn't think
they were going to pick up when I called
of course we did we knew Mary was
calling
they said Mary's on the phone we got
right on it
my question is I want to be a
millionaire by the time I hit 50 and I'm
46 going on 47 in September and my net
worth right now is 351. I'm on baby sick
maybe step six and I owe 293 in my
mortgage and my network my um income my
last year uh was 207 000. so you're 46.
I'm 46. okay and you have 350 000 in
your Investments and you're and you have
200 000 on your house owed what's the
house worth
[Music]
485k okay all right so your net Worth's
about 500 000 give or take
hello I
yeah uh I I thought it was 351. no the
equity in your house is is torture net
worth you owe 400 I mean you owe 200
it's worth 400 right there's about 200
Equity there and 350 is 500. so you got
you're about a half a million and how
much are you going to add to this
equation over the next four years
well
um
[Music]
and I want to be I want to pay off my
mortgage in two years but with inflation
and everything okay so you're going to
add a hundred thousand dollars a year
for four years to this equation first
two years pay off your mortgage and
after that to your Investments
are you
if you had four if you had a hundred
thousand dollars a year for four years
you're there
because you're already at 550.
plus 550 plus 4 is 950 and you're gonna
have some growth
[Music]
I didn't that's not fancy math that's
just quick first grade addition do you
understand what he did Mary he took your
net worth now which you you were not
calculating the equity in your home it
was 351 and then if you pay off your
house it's worth 4.85 you add that up
and then you're gonna have growth over
time as well over the next four years no
no no okay you got 350 and then you have
a paid off house by the time in two
years correct that's worth 500.
that's my goal okay but if you okay
that's a hundred a year for two years
right yeah okay if you do just a minute
stick with me okay if you have a paid
for 500 000 house two years from now
you add 350 to that is that not 8.50
hello
are you there
I'm here okay I'm here that's how you do
it and then the next two years you add a
hundred
to your Investments if your Investments
don't grow at all if you add a hundred a
year for the next four years to this
total equation the first two years to
the house the next two years to
Investments you're over a million if the
Investments don't grow at all so yeah
you're gonna be there way to go kiddo
you killed it that's great proud of you
touch down you did it you won the Super
Bowl now is a million dollars enough
that wasn't her question she just wants
to be a millionaire she just wants that
first Milestone to be there and uh and
and by age 50. so she's gonna actually
be a typical millionaire that we found
in the largest study of Millionaire's
ever done that Ramsay did and uh in that
basically we're going to find that just
a little less than half of her net worth
is in her home on the first million
dollars and the rest of it is in her
401k and in mutual fund Investments and
so that's how most of the one 1.5
million dollar net worth people we found
and oh by the way the average age was
52. that's great that's so young
it's getting younger every day yeah for
me it's just a puppy
[Laughter]
it's more than Young I can't believe
someone that young
but yeah yeah that's uh you did it
that's how you do it so you know and
here's the interesting thing okay
it's good to lay out your net worth and
not to obsess over it uh but to have
goals absolutely because then that
causes you to make positive moves
towards hitting your goals if you don't
do in other words whatever you don't do
on purpose languishes that's right
intentionality is everything in any area
of your life yep where there is no
vision people perish and you don't do
anything at all so you have a vision you
got to go through look at the numbers I
think a lot of people are afraid Dave to
even look at their retirement numbers or
see what it is that they can accomplish
in the time that they have set before
them yeah
surprised if you look and it really
doesn't I mean you don't have to spend
like days and days and days on this trip
when you go okay now what have I got to
do what must be true for me to put a
hundred a year out of my two and a
quarter income on these you know for
four years I'm 46 so that at 50 ding
ding I'm there yeah way to go Mary very
proud of you good work